So liebe leute jetzt platzt mir wirklich der kragen bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen scheint mit der klimaschutz wirklich komplett unter die räder zu kommen wir deutschen bekommen es einfach nicht hin nicht nur dass wir die
selbstgesteckten selbstgesteckten klimaziele nicht erreichen auch werden die bemühungen dazu
Im keim erstickt und jetzt achtung werden sogar kommerzielle unternehmen aktiv um die politik zur vernunft, zu bringen
Was ist da los leute hat eigentlich niemand den schuss gehört wie ist also die lage beim klimaschutz in deutschland jetzt bei pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen zu einem etwas meinungsstarken video
Wenn bundesverkehrsminister
Alexander dobrindt das ziel verbrennungsmotoren ab 2030 das ist noch lange hin nicht mehr zuzulassen als schwachsinn bezeichnet
Dann, frage ich mich wirklich wie er das den hitze orkan und sonstigen klima opfern in den nächsten jahrzehnten erklären will jetzt haben wir schon
millionen tote durch die folgen des klimawandels das ist wirklich einfach eine bodenlose
Unverschämtheit und komplettes unvermögen aber das hatten wir hier ja schon als das
bundesverkehrsministerium nicht in der lage war die rechtlichen grundlagen für die hyper look planung in deutschland
Zu klären ja zukunft und csu da scheinen zwei welten aufeinander zu prallen okay das war jetzt polemisch aber es kommt einem
So vor jetzt haben also die grünen auf dieses enddatum
2030 verzichtet und auch auf ein konkretes jahr für den endgültigen kohleausstieg
Wie bitte leute das geht nicht jetzt müssen sogar unternehmen also kommerzielle gewinnorientierte unternehmen
vorangehen um die wirklich von allen guten geistern verlassenen politiker und politikerinnen zur ordnung zu rufen
40 konzerne wie all die die telekom siemens die deutsche bahn adidas und so weiter und so fort
haben mit der stiftung zwei grad die zukünftigen regierungsparteien
aufgefordert zitat ein konsistentes konzept vorzulegen wie die 2020 ziele und die ziele des klimaschutzplan
2050 erreicht werden können
Das saß wie peinlich ist das denn die von uns gewählten
volksvertreter und vertreterin sind nicht in der lage für uns für das wohl ihres volkes die richtigen dinge zu tun
Was ist denn hier los man fühlt sich echt verraten und verkauft was treibt also einen verhandlungspartner alexander dobrindt
Zu und jetzt muss ich mal zur seiner äußerung sagen diesem schwachsinn es wäre lustig wenn es nicht
So ernst wäre deutschland wird die
selbstgesteckten klimaziele bis 2020 einfach mal nicht erreichen die bundesregierung hat auf ganzer linie versagt statt 40
Werden die treibhausgas emissionen lediglich um im besten fall 32 prozent gegenüber 1990 gesenkt und von einer million elektroautos
2020 da können wir nur träumen anfang 2017 waren es 34
Peinlich und jetzt kommt die autoindustrie noch mit ein paar lobbyisten
Eine lobbyistin also eine frau ist dabei. Da muss ich mir den plural jetzt mal sparen tatsächlich 14 männer und eine frau da sieht
Man mal direkt, wo die blödheit daheim ist wettern gegen elektroautos
Das sind alles übrigens professoren und experten fährverkehr nach eigener auskunft und die kritik an elektroautos ist wirklich und da wird man mir verzeihen
warum hier vom blödheit spreche schwachsinn achtung an zweiter stelle kritisieren sie die
Feinstaubbelastung durch ihre hohe beschleunigung wo man lieber gott lass hirn regnen was ist das denn ja es ist richtig
Ich kann, mit meinem elektro-smart an porsche versagen aber wie oft mache ich das wohl
Ich muss ehrlich sagen dass ich noch nicht so viele kavalier starts von
elektroautos gesehen habe und haben die lieben professoren auch berücksichtigt dass die elektroautos fast keinen abrieb an ihren
Bremsbelägen haben weil sie statt die bremsen zu nutzen mit
Ihrem elektro motor bremsen um energie zu gewinnen die kooperation nennt man das 100 quellen in diesem pamphlet
So muss man es mal nennen gibt es fast
Presseartikel und moment eine sekunde zwei studien und die belegen meines erachtens noch nicht mal die hauptthesen es ist also alles
nur nicht, wissenschaftlich und sie kritisieren dass elektroautos nicht
emissionsfrei sind sprich sie argumentieren gegen diese bezeichnung erklären dass es keine
emissionsfreie fortbewegung geben kann also erst mal ist das natürlich falsch fahrradfahrer
Im fußgänger und so weiter können die professoren eines besseren belehren und das ist damit auch gar nicht
Gemeint es geht ja darum dass diese fahrzeuge da wo sie fahren keine emissionen erzeugen also nicht andere
verkehrsteilnehmer
Vergiften das ist der punkt und selbst wenn sie also mit energie die aus kohle gas und so weiter gewonnen wird angetrieben werden dann wird
Dort in grösserem und effektiveren stil entgiftet als vor ort im straßenverkehr wo einfach kein gift das
Im boden näher ausgestoßen wird hingehört das ist schwachsinn herr dobrindt und bei
brady ladesäulen herr in berlin werden mit regenerativen energien gespeist und auch bei mir, zu hause
Gibt es ökostrom die vergleiche in diesem durchsichtigen versuch der autoindustrie
Einfluss auf die koalitionsverhandlungen zu nehmen hinken hinten und vorne ich könnte noch
So weiter machen das ist einfach hanebüchen
Wir brauchen jetzt einen umschwung und eine verlängerung des leidens wenn wir jetzt nicht handeln geht die ganze welt über die wupper
zumindest die menschheit wird das nicht überleben und ja ganze
entwicklungsabteilungen in deutschland müssen jetzt von
verbrennungsmotoren auf batterieentwicklung
Umschwenken die produktion muss umgestellt werden und und und ja
Das ist der wandel der zeit und wie so schön heißt wer nicht mit der zeit geht
Geht mit der zeit es ist so einfach und herr dobrindt
vielleicht sind sie der erste der das begreifen wird sagt jetzt habe ich dampf abgelassen
Sagt mir eure meinung soll ich ab und zu mal dampf ablassen und wir diskutieren hier unter dem video engagiert und fair
Schreibt sie die kommentare wenn er kein video von dix und verpassen wollt dann tut mir hier ein abo aufsaugen und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter, mit klimawandel bewiesen skeptiker endgültig widerlegt so ist es nämlich und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran